RFK Jr has gained some support on the
right
because he opposes some of the
corruption in the Democrat Party he was
right about kovid he's right about big
Pharma and some of the the capture
corporate capture of the federal
Regulatory Agencies but but RFK Jr now
that he's being floated as a potential
running mate for Donald Trump was asked
his views on important issues that
matter to conservatives notably the
issue of life and abortion here's
Kennedy's answer
is a decision toward a child should be
up to the women during the first three
months so you would cap it at 15 weeks
or 21 weeks
yeah for three months so three months
you would sign a federal cap on that
yes okay so not unlimited access to
abortion as many in the Democratic
language uh you know one's a child is
viable
outside the womb I think that the state
has an interest in protecting that child
that is at supersede and you know I
think that the state is an interest at
every level but at some point
I don't you know I'm against I'm for
medical freedom I think individuals
ought to be able to make their own
choice this is why I'm surprised to hear
you say you've happened well because you
know I think at some point you say to
say I would personally not
I think the states
um have a you know have a right
who uh to protect a child once the child
becomes
very sad answer very sad answer because
it's totally incoherent and
the reason it's incoherent is good
actually it's because Bobby Kennedy is
not just a run-of-the-mill Democrat who
just regurgitates all the crazy Democrat
points which now the Democrat talking
point on abortion is that we ought to
have abortion to the eighth trimester
you know it's should it's a wonderful
thing and we should celebrate it and
Kennedy's saying no no I don't I don't
think that I mean I support it
I support abortion I'm not one of those
crazy pro-lifers but yeah support it for
the first three months it's okay
she says only three months huh he goes
yeah yeah well the first three months of
life oh hold on wait you're saying
you're admitting that that it's life
that you're ending a human life in
abortion
so he's already he's kind a little bit
approaching the pro-life side he's
obviously at least open to it this is
but no but but you should obviously
oh I'm a Kennedy I'm a Democrat I have
of course abortion's good
but it is a life but okay so
really little really vulnerable life
it's okay to kill that but the older
life no the state has an interest in
protecting that life hold on so you
think she asks him you think that
that you shouldn't be able to have an
abortion later on that the state should
stop you well I'm for medical Freedom
huh so my proportion
well I'm for medical but I don't but I
don't think we should kill babies all
the time and well but
but I would I wouldn't personally oppose
abortion you personally I'm fine with
abortion up until the moment of birth
but I just think and you can it's just a
man who doesn't know what he thinks
about it which is fine so I don't want
to be too harsh on him I want to be
encouraging of Bobby Kennedy to just
examine this issue further and follow
his
I think probably correct recent
intuitions on this issue to their
logical conclusion if it's human if it's
life
if we want to protect people supposedly
his entire career is about protecting
people and the environment and from
predatory pharmaceutical companies then
you got to protect life you got to
protect human life simple as that you
got to be pro-life he doesn't know that
so maybe he could get on our side
someday maybe not I don't know uh but
he's obviously not on her side now and
it's just a reminder that
it's encouraging to see him oppose some
of the craziness on the left but it
he's not there yet he's not going to be
Trump's vice president he's not going to
be any Republicans vice presidential
running mate
uh
Kennedy's great contribution to this
race is to show that there is discontent
in populism serious populism 17 of the
party even on the left and that should
make us happy right now go to
goodranchors.com use code Knowles I
don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than it's
been in years and thanks to the
inflation we are feeling the heat in
more ways than one huh well the one
thing I'm not sweating this hot summer
is my meat price thanks to good ranchers
my price is locked in for two years you
might be thinking a price lock on meat
yes it's amazing and you need it how
does good ranchers do it I have no idea
because they've got higher quality meat
than any other company out there and
their prices are lower than all the
other companies and then they're locking
it in even with Joe Biden who is
president inflation so I don't know how
they're doing it but it's great and I
eat this food all the time and it's just
so freaking good everything they make is
terrific the stakes are out of control
and the burgers are the best I've ever
had add if you want it and you want it
for a great price all good American meat
go to goodranchors.com use code Knowles
Canada wles get 30 bucks off any bucks
that is promo code Knowles at
goodranchers.com goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered right now go to
helixsleep.com with everything going on
in the world right now you could use a
good night's sleep that is why you got
to check out Helix mattress he likes to
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite
Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences I've had my Helix
for years now I absolutely love it night
after night I sleep like a sweet
beautiful slumbering babe and I want the
same for you Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you want a mattress
for someone else get out of my mattress
I'm a married man go to Helix sleep.com
slash Knowles take their two minute
sleep quiz to find the perfect mattress
for your body and sleep type they're
flexible payment plans make it so that a
great night's sleep is never far away
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners hurry over to helixsleep.com
with Helix better sleep starts now this
is going to be controversial I don't
even know if I should say this
I'm going to irritate people but I'm not
here to Pander to you okay
I'm not here to tell you just what you
want here I'm here to tell you the truth
there's a study
shows that
half of U.S residents have tried
marijuana okay
I puff the devil's lettuce once or twice
in my wayward youth all right we've all
tried it
half of us I guess have tried it okay
I'm not listen people make mistakes
they experiment
17 of Americans currently
regularly smoke the thin spinach the
Peruvian parsley
California cumin you know what I'm
talking about
Jazz cigarettes you know what I mean
hashish is Hash is actually a little bit
different you know the Haitian oregano
talking about pot man they smoke it this
is according to a new Gallup survey
released on Thursday and I know before
I'm not I'm not gonna go
get on my high horse start talking about
how
pot is bad
and makes you
kind of
chubby and lazy and less funny though
you think everything else is funnier I'm
not gonna get on that highways
but to the people the conservatives who
say oh it's totally fine legalized pot
have everyone smoke I just have one
question this is a just a basic
political question do you think
that
the spread of marijuana use is likely to
make a more Americans more conservative
or more liberal
what do you think
do you think just all things being equal
you got a guy he's kind of politically
neutral and you say hey buddy come on
over here to the cigar bar and we're
gonna talk about GK Chesterton in
Edinburgh or you get a guy say hey buddy
come on down to the cool bar and we're
gonna throw back some beers not Bud
Lights and we're gonna hang out with the
boys and play poker
okay that's gonna push a guy into a
certain culture
or you say hey buddy come on over here
and start ripping out of this bong and
then we can all be in a drum circle and
engage in witchcraft like what
direction do you want to push people in
do you does anybody seriously believe
that more
potheads is going to make America more
conservative well if it's not if it's
obviously going to make America way more
hippie and dippy and liberal
then why would we be encouraging this
well say the Libertarians well because
of the Sacred right to smoke dope
no what right what right you think James
Madison wrote a right to smoke pot in
the Constitution I don't see that
what right the right that
Russell Kirk and Ronald Reagan and I
don't know any any conservative you name
John Adams and every any conservative in
American history you think
they really believe there's some
fundamental constitutional National
right to
smoke pot no obviously not
so what so why would we want it
cut it out guys just gonna make people
big Libs boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles show
we'll see you next time